Let's water bath some potatoes.
And I know what you're gonna say. Grace,
you can't water bath potatoes.
They're not a high acid food.
I am a rebel canner,
so I do what's comfortable in my kitchen.
You do what's comfortable in your kitchen,
but we are gonna be canning outside the USDA guidelines.
So you're also gonna take a very large bowl.
This is the bowl I'm using.
You're gonna fill this up with
like room temperature water.
Wash off your potatoes.
I'm using russet potatoes for this.
And you're gonna peel them
and then chop them into about a 1 inch pieces.
You're gonna drain off the potatoes
and you're gonna wash them at least three to four times
till your water runs clear.
Once you're done that,
you're gonna take some sterilized jars
and just put your potatoes in those sterilized jars.
I am then taking some of my red men's real salt
and we're going to do half a teaspoon in quarts
and then one fourth teaspoon in the pint.
Vinegar is optional,
but it cuts down your processing time.
So I did one tablespoon in quarts
and then half a tea tablespoon in pint.
You're gonna then take a spatula
some sort in deep,
bubble your jars.
This is just getting all the air bubbles out.
Clean the rims off with some vinegar,
clear away any of that debris on there.
And then put your lids on
and your rings on. Something
I like to Do is have a kettle with hot water on hand
next to my canner as I'm canning.
Because when you're water back canning
for longer period of time,
your water back canner,
the water is going to evaporate.
So this is just replacing that water
that is evaporating
at a rolling boil.
You wanna place your jars in.
I use a 2 inch head space for this process
for two hours.
And then when I take them out,
I let them sit for about five minutes in the canner,
transfer to a towel
and let them sit for 12 to 24 hours.
You wanna take the rings off after that
and make sure they are sealed properly.